en ce moment sur les écrans de cinéma on
parle beaucoup d'un sujet de société la
fin de vie il ya d'abord ce film entre
cinéma et documentaires où l'on pouvait
avoir les étapes des derniers jours de
la vie d'une femme qui avait choisi
l'euthanasie en suisse quelques heures
de printemps mercredi prochain toujours
sur les écrans amour le dernier film de
michael hanecke et palme d'or à cannes
avec un couple d'acteurs octogénaire
emmanuelle riva et jean louis
trintignant il est également question
dans ce film de la fin de vie alors que
l'héroïne
anne est victime d'une attaque cérébrale
elle se retrouve paralysé partiellement
nous avons en plateau ce soir pour
parler de ce film qui sera projeté lors
d'une avant première à l'ugc à luiz
lemaître bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
du réseau le pallium et puis jean-claude
caven bonsoir vous êtes le président de
l'association le pallium alors expliquez
nous pourquoi avoir organisé ce soir une
projection débat une rencontre autour de
ce film amour qui sera officiellement la
fiche de main mais on voulait justement
profité de la sortie de ce film pour
promouvoir justement parce qu'on appelle
l'ismans palliatifs un peu à tort des
ondes et on pourrait dire plutôt la
démarche par la démarche palliative
puisque ça ne concerne pas que la fin de
vie mais aussi toutes les maladies
graves que l'on peut accompagner vous
avez déjà découvert ce film vous l'avez
déjà vu on vous allez aussi de
décompression nous allons où leur
ordinaire ce matin la voiture quel est
le message qui est véhiculé justement à
travers ce film et qui va accompagner la
discussion le débat un médecin
généraliste est notamment sera présent
pour discuter avec le public ce soir je
crois que l'idée principale c'est
effectivement le huis clos qui se créent
dans cette situation d'un couple qui
effectivement monsieur l'accompagnant
madame et le fait qu'il y ait peu de
personnes autour d'eux et d'isolement
moi je trouve que c'est une chose très
importante qui apparaît dans ce film
c'est d'isolement et justement qu'est ce
que nous on peut mettre en place pour
éviter ce type de situation c'est la
question d'éventuels manques le public
va vous n'osez à l'issue de ce film on
va parler des actions que vous menez et
dont vous allez parler forcément ce soir
après la projection du film amours en
avant première à l'ugc ciné-cité skywest
on regarde la bande annonce il ya
quelqu'un
tout à l'heure quand je suis entré je me
suis rappelé comment je vous écoute est
toujours faire l'amour comme ça donnait
le sentiment que vous vous aimez et pour
eux seraient toujours ensemble
kinga qu'est ce qu'il ya
nous constatons qu
je suis se passe
qui ne va quand même pas mal mené ton
image sortait bien jour je me ferais
bien ici moi même
tuer un monstre parfois le may évoqué ce
qu'il est devenu fou non mais je veux
pas m'asseoir
qu'est ce qu'ils sont
mais
à
voilà pour la bande annonce de ce film
d'année qui sera projeté ce soir à
montigny le bretonneux à l'ugc débat
discussion à suivre organisée notamment
par le pallium 7 cette soirée quel est
l'objectif pour vous est présenté toutes
les activités que vous proposez qui sont
méconnus finalement pour cet
accompagnement en fin de vie c'est à la
fois effectivement permettre au public
de connaître les activités et
l'existence du pallium c'est aussi pour
l'association de montrer et fille de
faire connaître tout ce qui est la
démarche palliative et d'un petit peu de
familiariser le public avec les notions
de soins palliatifs de mort et
d'accompagnement quels sont les types
d'accompagnement plus précisément qu'on
peut mettre en place quelle structure
existe c'était la directrice du réseau
alors il existe de nombreuses structures
d'abord il ya une équipe mobile qui peut
se déplacer à domicile et aller rendre
visite aux patients en lien avec les
médecins généralistes toujours des
patients puisque on ne ne fonctionne que
si le médecin généraliste est d'accord
et l'équipe va donc après faire une
évaluation de la situation avec médecins
généralistes et éventuellement d'autres
soignants il ya également un certain
nombre de services qui sont donc permis
notamment la stran téléphonique 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
il ya des groupes de soutien pour les
patients il ya éventuellement une
possibilité de soutien psychologique
il ya des marches pour des personnes
endeuillées voilà il ya de multiples la
présence de bénévoles d'accompagnement
possible il ya beaucoup de talent parle
véritablement d'accompagner une
compagnie sur cette question de
l'euthanasie comment vous positionner
parce que c'est aussi une question qui
fait débat dans la société j'évoquais
tout à l'heure le film quelques heures
de printemps un humain avec le
documentaire la ouvertement la question
était posée un de pratiquer une
euthanasie
quelle est la position quelle position
vous avez là dessus l'autre film sa part
le mois d'août a nazi ça parle d'eux
le suicide assisté ce qui est un peu
pareil mais la question est un peu
différente à mon avis nous notre
position les est le cas nous en quoi
justement aussi c'est différent
peut-être entre l'euthanasie et le
suicide assisté
disons que la personne décide elle-même
il fait 20 ans alors qu'elle était
encore fort bonne santé complètement
conscient puisqu'il ya il ya une
démarche voulue de la personne et donc
c'est la nuance que que vous y mettez
est un nazi en principe on demande à un
tiers de donner la mort 2 alors que le
suicide assisté c'est la personne elle
même qui se donne la mort dans cette
question de l'euthanasie je vous lis et
précisez votre position juste en
précisant auparavant que 86% des
français semble aujourd'hui plutôt
favorable à la légalisation de
l'euthanasie
c'était un sondage ifop publié début
octobre dans le magazine pèlerin
magazine
alors votre position moi c'est non dans
notre position la question était posée
était pas simple demande effectivement
des réponses simples oui ou non à des
questions très compliquées et très
personnelle donc effectivement les gens
ne veulent pas souffrir
ils veulent pas se retrouver dans une
situation de dramatique donc c'est
normal s'il disait
qui n'était pas pour l'amour si
compliqué donc vous êtes plutôt contre
voilà revenir ouvertement les choses
pour préciser il s'est pas franchement
content c'est à dire que le principe ce
n'est pas d'être pour ou d'être contre
le principe c'est d'entendre une demande
d'euthanasie et de l'étudier et de voir
un petit peu quelle réponse on peut y
apporter
c'est bien souvent quand y ait une
demande voilà comme bien souvent il ya
d'abord effectivement qu'on me dit
jean-claude plusieurs demandeurs ça peut
être le patient lui-même
voilà ça peut être la famille donc ça
c'est une réponse aussi différentes ça
peut être les soignants aussi qui ne
supporte pas une situation de gaulle a
donc après on étudie la situation on
écoute on étudie on voit ce qu'il ya
comme réponse à apporter dans de
nombreuses situations
ce sont souvent des problématiques de
douleur qui font que les patients
effectivement en nous assénant peuvent
plus de ce supplément sur la loi 2005 la
loi leonetti qui permet d'éviter les
traitements déraisonnable et tout
acharnement thérapeutique se disent en
bonne voie bien sûr toute assez elles
répondent dans la majorité des cas a
énormément de situations
le tweed effectivement d'abord de faire
comprendre l'acide d'entendre la
situation de l'écouté de l'étudier et de
pouvoir apporter des réponses
je dis pas qu'on répondra tout on est
comme tout le monde on peut sans
répondre à connaître cette loi qui est
sur cette question de l'euthanasie même
si c'est plus compliqué a résumé que
pour rencontre nous avons tout de même
posé à la question à quelques yvelinois
cet après-midi connaître un petit peu
leur santé oms autour de cette question
de l'euthanasie
pour quelle raison parce que j'ai mon
mari qui est décédé d'une maladie mais
les maladies orphelines gelé vu souffrir
pendant deux ans je suis à 200% pour
l'euthanasie contre parce que j'ai des
convictions je pense que toute vie à
mérite d'être respecté je peux pas
répondre pour ou contre je crois que ça
dépend vraiment
trente six 36 solutions
moi j'ai eu proche de moi quelqu'un
voilà j'ai décidé de l'emmener quand
même à l'hôpital qui se fait opérer
quatre aînés deux ans de plus comme ça
et je je l'aurais pas emmener et je m'en
voudrais je les emmenais je m'en veux
pas de bonne solution
globalement je serais plutôt pauvre oui
pour quelles raisons pour des raisons
habituelles c'est à dire diminuer les
souffrances des gens quand on sait qu'il
ya plus d'espoir et que c'est terminé
quoi je serais plutôt pour mais pas
comment dire faut pas que ça dépend
d'une personne faut que ce soit une
réunion de deux médecins deux
dans la famille enfin faut pas que ce
soit la décision d'une ou deux personnes
l'euthanasie moi je serais plutôt pour
moi parce que je pense que chacun a
droit de décider son sa fin de vie
surtout des personnes atteintes de
maladies incurables
voilà pour ces quelques réactions
éventuellement des projets de loi qui
pourrait être déposée allant dans ce
sens légalisation de l'euthanasie on
entendu votre position sur cette
question tout à l'heure on va revenir
juste pour conclure sur la soirée débat
que vous proposez autour du film amours
d'un hockey et qui parlent de cette
question de de soins palliatifs
d'accompagnement en fin de vie par
rapport aux différents dispositifs qui
existent que vous avez pu mettre en
place combien de personnes vous
accompagner tout au long de l'année sur
2011 si je vous donne des chiffres sur
2011 on a accompagné un peu plus de 420
familles puisqu'on en campagne le
patient mais aussi sa famille donc des
situations concernent les abeilles
électrique dans le centre absolument oui
tout à fait le soutien série à la stran
téléphonie qui a les visites régulières
de l'équipe pour soutenir les familles
il ya la présence de bénévoles qui
peuvent permettre aussi un espace
d'écouté pour les familles il ya des
groupes de soutien également pour qu'ils
puissent rencontrer d'autres familles
qui partagent les mêmes difficultés
et donc voilà ça permet de se soulager
quand on partage ses propres difficultés
et un tabou à venir vous voir aussi
quelquefois qu'un échauffement oui bien
sûr bien sûr mais on a quand même cette
arrière-pensée de la fin de vie est plus
ou moins proche mais ya quand même cette
arrière-pensée de la fin de vie aussi
c'est pour ça que l'un des matelas
voilà mais c'est pour ça qu'on essaye de
travailler pour faire connaître les
soins palliatifs bien plus en amont
sachant que les souabes actif ça ne veut
pas dire fin de vie c'est une prise en
charge bien plus en amont de toute la
pâte de tout où l'individu dans son
entier merci de votre intervention que
ce soir à 19h45 projection à l'ugc
autour du film amours dan qu'il y aura
une discussion débat avec le pallium qui
organise cette soirée pour parler soins
palliatifs accompagnement en fin de vie
merci à vous deux dans un instant nous
parlons sport la chronique et sports du
lit
10 et puis à suivre ce soit également
une rencontre avec un auteur et qui nous
parlera de son parcours entre le sénégal
et la france il est également conseiller
municipal à montigny le bretonneux pour
l'instant le sport